in class you you emphasize that we're
working with basic laws of physics so I
just read Einstein's biography he was
obsessed with finding a single theory
that would unify all the fundamental
forces of nature Wow
do you think there exists the unified
theory of grappling we can boil
everything down to just a few principles
I will
well first off if Einstein wasn't able
to come up with a unified theory I would
sincerely question my ability to go that
way but do I believe that something like
that could potentially exist absolutely
and I think that even if it doesn't a
belief in the possibility of it and the
search for it would would leave you
better off than where you started
whereas if I was a no no that's [ __ ]
that would never and then I don't look
even if I'm right because I didn't look
there's certain things I won't learn so
I think you know a lot of times just
let's say alchemy the idea that you're
going to turn lead to gold all right
let's a little bit nuts but who knows
maybe that's that kind of nutty and you
know on highly unlikely is highly
unlikely probability of success pursuit
yielded scientific progress elsewhere in
the search for that even though again
someone would look back and say oh
that's stupid who would blush and who
would do that
well if you spent years trying to figure
it out I guarantee you're going to learn
some other things as well so I think
that there at the very least the
principle based approach to grappling is
incredibly important with your process
like for learning new details and
understanding the principles behind the
techniques I certainly don't believe
that I have like a singular or perfect
approach by any stretch of the
imagination but you know I guess what I
try to do is block out extraneous
nonsense like for instance both Pete a
lot of people want to talk about 55
details and reasons for something that's
going on and the reality is is that
you're clouding your thought process for
instance there was a recent not to get
too political but there was a recent
issue where I remember an inmate was
executed and they used a new drug and it
was painful and oh my god and he died it
was horrible again that's when whether
you believe that capital punishment is
valid or not I think there's plenty of
arguments against it in fact I think
most of the arguments that make sense
are against it but pain has fuck-all to
do with it you know I don't care that's
like done hey Lex I'm going to kill you
but don't worry it's not going to hurt
man I mean don't know okay then yeah
it's like that doesn't make it okay it's
like believe me I'm for free I'm is
again if you're gonna kill me I prefer
that you don't burn me at the stake but
if someone was like don't worry it's not
even a sting I'm still going to try to
fight you to the death I'm absolutely
not allowing this to happen if someone
wants to say okay hold on let's get
let's cut the [ __ ] like feely
feelings out of here and say look forget
the pain does this person deserve it
uh-uh
let's let's step that back again is
there a potential for human error is
there potential for someone having this
guy behind bars for political gain like
okay these are the real reasons that you
say hey no way on the death penalty it
has nothing to do with does it hurt or
which drug is it are blah-dee-blah
or is it inhumane it's like none of that
if hey we're focusing on the wrong thing
so it reminds me of jiu-jitsu in the
same sense and again we're fighting were
generally speaking in my opinion debates
that happen in the public you know arena
they always focus on the wrong dang
thing and always focus on the wrong
aspect again there's 25 good reasons or
bad reasons to do almost anything but
generally speaking people will focus on
the hundred other ones that are
extraneous and [ __ ] so what I want I
guess what I would say is it reminds me
of jiu-jitsu is striking like man Floyd
likes to hold his hand this way or that
way or the other way and and this guy
likes to jab like this and it's really
important this person says you land with
this knuckle in that person says you
land with net knuckle and in jiu-jitsu
it's very very important that you grip
three inches up on the lapel and two to
the right
but Roger Gracie doesn't like this but
cabrini says it like this clearly they
all work under the right circumstances
and don't work on to the wrong ones and
it has nothing to do or very little to
do with these other things like hey does
it matter again I'm going to kill you
would you prefer for it to be painless
or horrific ly painful okay if it's
already a foregone conclusion death
alright yeah now we'll start to talk
about the the extreme like whether or
not it's going to sting but until we get
to that point
hey let's focus on the do we is it even
right or do I have the ability or the
capacity to do this justifiably okay so
that's where you come down to the
principles in my opinion say all right
yeah it doesn't matter which knuckle you
land with yeah I'm sure it does but it's
a hell of a lot less important than 25
other little things that make all of the
difference and in my experience a lot of
coaches and a lot of people particularly
guys that are trying to [ __ ] you
will focus on 45 little details and oh
it's there's 15 details to this ten
okay that's true but what are the two
most important ones because hey don't
get me wrong I'm not saying that these
details don't matter but just like
anything else in life there's a
hierarchy because would you say that
would you say that happiness and
self-actualization is a valuable thing
in life yes I would as well and you know
what we have the luxury of saying that
type of thing because we're sitting at
fifty fifty Jitsu in Falls Church
Virginia and there's no one trying to
kill us rape us and we are also I know
where food is tonight yeah if you were
to walk down if you were to talk to
someone like 2,000 years ago I'll be
like how are you feeling they would
stare a chili what are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm starving yeah I'm hungry
that's my issue
are you are you satisfied in your life
it's like I'll be satisfied when you get
out of my way so I can find some food so
that's even the deeper question is are
you eating something tonight right and
so it's Maslow's hierarchy of needs when
we take care of the base needs first
then we start to work our way up toward
self-actualization and this and that and
but until you got your food water
shelter don't tell me about where you're
placing your grip it's like you're all
leaning out and you're you know your
posture is poor and you're out of
balance and you want to tell me your
grip that's like I'm starving to death
the you know the barbarians are at the
gates but I'm sitting here giving you a
philosophy lesson it's like this is
[ __ ] it doesn't make any sense
build a better wall a sharper knife and
get some food and then we'll cover all
the other stuff so I think that in my
when it comes to how I approach martial
arts in terms of learning as well as
teaching I really try to boil it down to
what I feel to be the most important
component parts and then if I one day
reached the level of where these tiny
details matter that's fantastic because
again the difference between you know
the ability to pass that try to pass
successfully against a cabrini or how
file Mendez and against a regular
run-of-the-mill black belt or you know
does come down to little details but
it's also presupposing that you're in
proper position that even allow these
details become relevant and I think that
a lot of times we put the cart before
the horse and that's not that's
problematic there's still in your
opinion undiscovered position
submissions of techniques and you just I
would say that there have to be there
absolutely are um you know I think that
what we see is jiu-jitsu now don't get
me wrong the core never changes because
physics doesn't change physics is the
same thing that's why I get a kick out
of
love like self-defense arguments it's
like [ __ ] it has another no physical
difference in self-defense beyond the
fact yes you can I guess mean though
I've never seen anything like that in
real life that you're crossing a pretty
serious psychological line if you're
putting your knuckles to you know your
thumb to knuckles deep into somebody's I
forget the fact that did you know that
we're legal more all other things like
that it's like I've never done that
before I wouldn't do it lightly there
probably be some hesitation there what
is so anyway what makes it different is
the the psychological component and all
these other things going on but
physically there's no difference again
people like Aldridge it's is really
different in MMA no it's not not in my
opinion not in my experience it is
absolutely not what are you talking
about physics are different inside of a
cage than they are on a mat and they are
out in a field
it's exactly the same now if I try to
sport grapple you under a non sport
grappling rule set then I may run myself
into trouble but that had nothing to do
with jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu is physics is
proper expression of physics the same
way boxing is and the same way of
wrestling is the same way all these
things are so I would say that as long
as something adheres to the principles
that that allow something to be
effective and you know and fundamentally
sound that you can do almost anything
and I think that people will continue
particularly in the ghee it's going to
get nuts you know just the level of the
amount of things that you can get away
with and do and different grips that you
can make but I'd say what we're looking
at right now is going to look only
somewhat like what jujitsu is going to
look like in 30 years the same way the
jujitsu we see now is so much
fundamentally better honestly and and
more evolved and adaptive than it was
twenty years ago and people will swear
up and down like all back in the day
it's back in the day people did not
fight very well even twenty years ago
the level of people understanding how to
deal with jujitsu was very reduced so
you could get away with all sorts of
pretty questionable stuff like sitting
in front of someone in close guard and
have them not completely kick the [ __ ]
out of you but um yeah I think you know
with particularly the advent of Baron
bull the 50/50 position all these
different things which have always
existed there's they've always existed
and one that's I always hesitate to say
invent I don't like the word invent like
that certain people use a lot
I'd say Discoverer because you could
show me I can come up with something
let's say Lex you know you've got a
really good straight foot lock I was
watching a train last night
and I could be doing that in a way that
no one ever taught me that doesn't mean
I invented it because you've been doing
it forever but basically it's let's say
no one showed me the details you were
using and I managed to stumble across
them I didn't invent those details eyes
go yeah I discovered them that was neat
but again none of us have invented a
dang thing people have had two arms and
two legs for certainly as long as I can
remember and probably longer than that
and today here yeah that's that's the
word so in the history books
you